Bonjour ou voici de ces bons résultats
Alors
Donc, donc, donc, donc..
Bien alors il paraît qu'on est dans le making-of de la science de l'amour.
Voix : Avez-vous déjà pensé à être infidèle ?
Voix : Avez-vous pensé à être possessif ?
Voix :  (?) amante
Voix : Avez-vous des choses à cacher ?
Voix : Avez-vous des choses à cacher ? (écho)
Timothée : Je lui ai proposé de réaliser un court métrage
Cyprien : Et là on s'est rencontrés et il m'a raconté cette histoire de quantifier l'amour et j'aimais bien l'idée, euh..
d'avoir un truc un peu drame et aussi un truc de couples.
Timothée : C'est vraiment intéressant en fait parce qu'on avait à chaque fois des réunions pour essayer de rendre vraiment le tout meilleur,
faire en sorte que ce soit le plus efficace possible et on se plaise tous les deux dans le court métrage
que le court métrage me plaise.
Cyprien : Ouais. Timothée : Voilà.
Cyprien : C'est la fin de ta phrase ça donc ?
Timothée : Ouais x3
*Rires*
Le personnage de Milo,
il y a un moment un peu charnière de sa vie où il va se marier avec
avec sa copine ça fait longtemps qu'ils sont ensemble. Il y a ce fond de jalousie et de
paranoïa et peu de répliques par exemple c'est tout bête mais comme ça se passe beaucoup dans sa tête et tout
et qu'il a du mal sur l'engrais ouais ouais
et en plus c'est le mariage va arriver donc elle se dit ok c'est pas grave il est dans sa phase de parano mais je
vais garder jusqu'au mariage tout seul mais il est tellement insistant et tellement relou finalement
que craque et que c'est donc là la scène finale où
elle explose, elle débite tout en fait sur le personnage de Flora bien sûr. Dans notre tête c'était vraiment cette personne toujours
positive, quelqu'un qui a toujours le sourire et l'idée c'était que elle elle prenne tout et qu'elle ne dit rien.
Et que la relation soit plein de non-dits en fait. Mais toi tu descends tout vers le bas
Tellement de fois que a un moment donné, ca craque
Toi, tout ce que tu trouve à faire pendant cette période c'est passer un putain de test pour savoir à quel point on serait compatibles !
Moi je vois ça comme un truc quand même de douceur encore dans ce truc. Et je me dis on a la scène d'avant !
Pendant le dernier jour de tournage et à partir de l'après-midi ma seule réplique que je vais faire, c'était dire :
Sean Bean
Je vous le mets là : "Bah il est aussi dans le Seigneur des anneaux : *Sean Ben*. - Sean Bean - Voilà. C'est bon vous avez profité de cette réplique
Pendant 5 heures, j'ai dis que cette phrase là.
Tu me la refais ?
Cyprien : Sean Bean. Oh putain j'y arrive plus tu vois. C'est pour ca qu'on l'a travaillé 5 heures de suite.
*rires*
C'est le gros gros gros business. Je veux dire à un moment donné il faut bien payer les vacances !
* Parle dans un micro *
Alors moi je suis plutôt le personnage du docteur dans l'histoire il se fait un peu surprendre à son propre jeu et il a lancé ça
et il fait pas trop le malin parce que.. bah il vient de briser un couple.
On imagine une sorte de chercheurs, quelqu'un qui est vraiment bossé un peu toute sa vie sur comment quantifier
les émotions. Toute la dernière partie pour la fin jusqu'au revealed on va le suivre un peu plus on va se mettre de son point
de vue ils se rendent compte pas que tout part en vrille et que c'est pas une très bonne idée
On a eu combien de décors ?
Combien de décors différents Ben ?
Une dizaine
Une dizaine de décors. Il y'a eu des petits décors par exemple quand on fait un
essayage ou même dans la voiture où ça, ça va assez vite
Pour nous les endroits clés c'est surtout la salle d'attente et la salle du thelle ( salle d'attente et salle thuelle ) donc c'est ça c'est tout l'univers de
l'aspect technologique en fait de cette histoire de ce que la société s'appelle lovecount mais
tout ça nous on voulait que ce soit graphique donc on est dans une sorte de petit système qui
sert à prendre en photo à la base
des visages sous tous les angles
un studio qui fait ça pour le cinéma le jeu vidéo et nous on s'en sert on détourne ça pour faire comme si c'était une
petite ambiance de test chelou.
* Esco * c'est une société technologique qui est spécialisé dans la création et l'animation de double numérique. c'est a dire des modèles 3D
que l'on utilise pour reproduire l'apparence et le jeu de célébrités sur les films le jeu vidéo
Voix : (?) Vous considéré-vous possessif ?
On a pu avoir accès en fait à des patterns qui
qui nous ont codés. Nous, on a une sorte d'interface ici et on peut choisir ce qu'on ressert donc à chaque fois qu'il y avait une
réponse à la question si je voulais en faire un flash je flashait et ca faisait le flash
Vous voyez la caméra ? Non ! Tu vois pas où est la caméra ? Regarde par ici ! Non !
Au sol peut être ...
Au plafond peut être ...
Par ici elle est cachée juste là eh oui ...
Combien dedans, la, dans la boîte ?
2 .
Allez, on y retourne tout le monde ?
On est à l'espace
Niemeyer et est en fait, le siège du parti communiste qui a une architecture très particulière il y a eu pas mal de tournages ici
Y'a eu le film ''Au poste'' de Quentin Dupieux, il y a eu pas mal de clips et de publicités
L'idée, c'était d'avoir un côté un peu un peu hôpital psychiatrique la rave c'était beau le
dire à tout un aspect bureaucratique avec
les tests la manière de l'expliquer les dossiers . C'est combien ? La formule, euh, c'est 1500 euros. Je peux te parler 5 minutes ?
Et celle en trois mois là ? Et bah c'est celle-ci 1500 euros.
Ah non la formule express. Après la scène de dîner on a trois plans sur la serrure qui se ferme
C'est pour accentuer voilà c'est ce côté où on appuie sur
sur certains points que Milo
semble voir que.. qui semble anodin en fait mais que Milo, suranalyse.
Ce qui est assez amusant c'est qu'on a totalement déstructuré le scénario pendant le montage on a des séquences qui était censées
apparaître dans, vers le début du film finalement . Par exemple à 3 minutes du film, qui finalement apparaissent à 13 minutes du film .
Voilà, on a ajusté plein de petits trucs comme ça pour que l'élément déclencheur arrive plus tôt . Oui voila c'est ca !
Et la parano soit plus longue c'est ce qu'on appelle la troisième écriture. C'est a dire qu'au début donc tu
écris ton histoire ensuite tu la réécris un peu avec les comédiens sur le tournage et puis ensuite au montage tu la réécris encore une nouvelle fois
en changeant peut-être en raccourcissant la c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire et aussi la musique est très importante parce que la on commence à
intégrer la musique aussi c'est un moment très satisfaisant dans le montage. On rajoute aussi les intentions dans la musique
qui est composée par Guillaume Férrand c'est une quatrième écriture je dis mais oui c'est vrai c'est une quatrième écriture parce que
Ok on a eu, euh..
on a un moment où je sais pas quelqu'un il est en train de
tuer une personne si tu mets une musique qui raconte ce moment et qui fait peur parce qu'il est en train de tuer la personne
finalement ça ne fait qu'accompagner la scène et c'est pas si (Cyprien : Oui) intéressant que ça. C'est une musique plus douce tu peux dire :
Ah tiens il y'a peut-être du regret dans cette affaire, si tu mets un truc drôle tu dis : Ah mais il est peut-être pas vraiment mort
Euh, c'est...
donc c'est vrai c'est une quatrième écriture
* Ok tout le monde c'est une fin de tournage !!! *
* Applaudissements *
Je tiens à dire que c'était un super
tournage et c'était aussi super enrichissant d'écrire des histoires que j'ai pas besoin d'imaginer. Un gros big up à toute l'équipe, à tout..
.. à tout le monde et aussi aux internautes qui ont suivi cette petite aventure
dramatique.
Voilà.